today we're playing table tennis vs
tennis horse and we're joined by Serbian
tennis pro boyana jovanovic so are you
ready for the battle I'm ready and good
luck to you I think we're going to need
some good luck here you will first off
classic ATM
boyana are scared
have you done around the net in tennis
before this is actually first time but I
will do it
another one Pamela are you ready for
boyana's tennis serves I've been
preparing for this one my whole life
should be good
if you can return my serve we'll get a
letter
first one to drop the egg loses this
will be really hard it's raw I'm not
ready
[Music]
so you have to get the ball to bounce
back to you a gold serve sounds pretty
scary like that so this one it looks
hard
we have to come up with something she
can do
let's see Sensei yourself
it's not easy as it looks like
[Music]
not make it easy for him I have some
confidence in Auto like he's a good
tennis player I'm fairly decent
[Music]
he's angry
Sensei well done tested them we can work
with that one but you got a point for
Punk finity okay boy on a ski shooting
next
oh
nice easy
[Music]
oh no luck a letter for us okay let's
try now to pick up the ball on different
ways okay first one
sure next one so from here
I can't believe that worked
oh that was smooth
[Music]
is that enough this is getting more
football skills
count
let's count
three in a row
[Music]
foreign
no no okay
this is called ping pong tennis tennis
I'm really excited to try this to be
honest
[Music]
oh they are supposed to get it back this
is too easy guys come on
Wow Let's Go the pricing easy that looks
so easy we brought in the wrong wheel so
this is the actual Target
[Applause]
you have the hardest part here
[Music]
one letter for us so I'm gonna have a
Target on top of my head whichever one
of you knocks it off first wins I'm not
too worried about Otto's ping pong
smartphone
tennis ball is a bit concerning
[Music]
we have a winner congratulations now I
need to learn on finish and you are a
voiced yeah because you won perfect
yes yeah yes go and follow her on
Instagram and huge thanks to God thank
you guys so much I really enjoyed see
you in the next video